what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so I've been waiting all day for
this Tomb Raider trailer to drop it
wasn't too excited about this movie but
then yesterday I did some research on it
and I found out it was based off the
2013 video game reboot I was like oh
that's pretty cool not too familiar with
it and I don't have time to play the
whole game so yesterday I I did the lazy
man's version of playing a game I went
on YouTube watched the entirety of the
game play and the cutscenes tomb rated a
2013 edition because I heard this
movie's gonna heavily borrow from that
one after watching it I kind of want to
share some of my anticipation thoughts
if you want to skip straight to the
reaction here's the time mark right here
if you want to hop right to the reaction
part so know some of you guys are like
you take too long I don't like actual
commentary the part where you're
creating your own content I don't like
that so I want to be my anticipation
thoughts what I'm hoping this movie does
is give us a strong character on Lara
Croft what I love about her journey in
the videogame was her story of becoming
a survivor when her story begins she's
this young female archaeologist hoping
to discover you know something
monumental make a name for herself and
she's not that confident herself she
feels a pressure to uphold her Croft
name you know live up to the image that
her father laid out or living in her
father's shadow would have been a
smarter way to say that one and for
those who played the game when the ship
crashes onto the island she has to truly
grow to survive this mission I don't
know if the movies gonna be doing this
but I really appreciated how it was
Lara's decision to go take that specific
route to that Island and then she felt
this weight of responsibility this guilt
on her shoulders that this is all her
fault that the entire crew of the ship
is now stranded some died some are in
peril when I was watching these
cutscenes I was thinking there's some
real great opportunity for some strong
storytelling in a movie I can easily see
how this can be adapted into a film
because in the beginning of her having
to survive she's really on her own she's
frightened but she takes action to live
she kills deadly animals and deadly
human inhabitants of the island the
other character in the game that I
looked on IMDB this character isn't
credited in the movie which is kind of a
bummer because I really liked him in the
game the character raw he says a line to
her that I wrote dad so I made sure
didn't get it right I mean get it wrong
I got that one wrong
professes a choice you make losses a
choice made for you and that line to me
is a big part of order character arc
entails it's a story of her learning to
hone in and trust her creative instincts
and survival instincts the character
grows from the scared woman with a lack
of faith in herself to a strong powerful
and kind of dangerous woman she becomes
a fighter at the end but I primarily
took away from watching the hours of
Kane play in the cutscenes there's a
great chance for an actual strong
character in this video game adaptation
of a film but of course even seem like
the Instagram teaser trailer was like
well they're gonna show us the action
sequences and there's some great
potential for some awesome action
sequences as well what I really loved
about her character kind of reminded me
of Nathan Drake I don't know if these
guys are the same creators or not when
she's fighting in the game she's
constantly struggling she grunts she
makes noises she's in pain and she takes
energy for her sometimes to hurt people
or strike or climb things I like that
part of her that felt very human which
made it easier to get on board with I'm
just watching the game play and not
actually playing it she has to hone in
on her strength and motivation and she
gets hurt so when I was watching the
gameplay it sort of made me think this
could also be an opportunity to sort of
be like a modern-day action film with
like action inspirations from films such
as the revenant or Apocalypto but
modern-day where it's this one woman
versus nature
cuz yes she fights a lot of human she
kills some animals but a lot of it is
her fighting environment she gets
trapped in water rapids she has to
survive the jungle and deadly beasts in
the jungle and then there's whether the
condition she has to fight against and
you know when they're killing the humans
and some of the animals you know I'm
thinking to myself like is this video
game adaptation gonna be rated R I feel
like a lot of the time some video game
adaptations are rated R but I feel like
this one might not be nor does it really
need to be rated or I could see how they
can make this story and not have it be
that bloody although I think it would be
way cooler if it was rated R I gotta say
that the director Aurora who THOG I
think is his name I should have wrote
that down I would have been smart at me
I could see how he's a good choice for
this adaptation from what I read about
is I think 2015 filmed the way there was
a disaster movie that surprisingly had a
lot of characters as a main focus which
made the disaster stuff even more
impactful even though I heard it was
cliched
it was actually a really good flick
because the character was good in an
action movie or a disaster film and with
Lara Croft being a character not only
fights off humans she has to battle with
surviving nature I could see if this
director hones in on the strengths of
what his last film did puts it into here
and gives us a good character I could
see this being a solid film that's all
my anticipation thoughts of what I'm
hoping this trailer will help me feel
solidified it by the time I'm done
watching it I know I won't be able to
judge it until the final product comes
out however I'm hoping the trailers
communicates to me that there's
definitely a possibility it'll be there
did we go
[Music]
Danny read there it is Papes
if you're listening to this to mother of
damn ouch is he Mathias
[Music]
ouch nice
[Music]
it's like so cool
[Music]
Nick Frost I'll take two I love that huh
it was pretty sweet that was pretty
sweet I liked it you know you gotta be
weary of video game adaptations though
man you gotta be weird game adaptation
sometimes they have some really bomb
trailers and more often than not they're
not the greatest movies so far I know I
gave a bunch of my anticipation thoughts
it looks to be giving me a lot of what I
was hoping for a personal lara croft
tale as something that the trailer
really communicated to me she's going to
this island where her father went
missing she's trying to prove herself
the action sequences the environment
that all looks similar to the video game
and in the 2013 video game that this is
being heavily inspired from an in
feature Laura's dad in it he just talked
about how she feels she's living in his
shadow and you could still feel that
weight of responsibility here in
Alicia's performance that's one thing
you got to give the trailer that they're
really communicating is this is a
personal journey that she's going on but
I appreciate about differences that they
made was there's not a whole bunch of
crew members although I kind of would
have liked a cast but it allows us to be
primarily just invested in who Laura is
and who than ever the supporting
character Asian guy is and yay Asians
diversity and I talked about on my
anticipation thoughts how I didn't want
Laura to seem like this character who
really just has a handle on everything
you know like Angelina Jolie's Laura
Croft loosing like she just handled
business like him like it was nothing
here I like that it seems like she's
struggling granted there's some scenes
here where she would probably look a lot
Messier but because she's a female lead
in a huge studio film they're not gonna
dirty her up too much in the video game
Laura gets beat quite a lot yeah I
thought like oh and the trailer maybe
we'll get some images of her getting
light bruised up and looking really
dirty but for the most part her makeup
looks really intact it seems to be an
exciting adventure tale I love all the
imagery of her dodging a lot of things
the name from running across logs and
being on top of the waterfall having to
jump into that abandoned airplane her
dealing with nature and environmental
circumstances that's everything I did
want to see in terms of action sequences
of course you know you got the that
the name of the mountain climbing ax
thingy which is a great weapon which can
make for some hard our violence but I
don't think this film is gonna be a hard
our bow and arrow of course I don't
think this film looks like it's gonna be
perfect there's some dialogue moments
like this sounds like really cliche
Hollywood dialogue you know all the
stuff about her father dad even saying
in the videotape if you're watching this
someday like there's a lot of cliche
sounding dialogue however I don't feel
this film needs to be the greatest thing
in the world I need it to be good enough
to open up a door for better video game
movies and I feel like it has the
potential to do that
it seems very character based on who
Lara Croft is it's a personal story but
you also got some cool adventure
the CGI does look fantastic this looks
like it must have been a very physically
demanding role for Alicia vikander I
don't understand her name Alicia
vikander whatever this trailers being
truthful the vibe I'm getting is that
this journey is a very personal mission
for her so the stakes on any cool
adventure sequence that she's going
through will be raised because this is a
very personal journey that she's going
on walton goggins as a bad guy Mathias
thinking of the video game Mathias seems
like he's very different than how
they're translating him into the movie
in the game the Mathias and his people
have been stranded there for years here
looks like Walton Goggins hasn't been
there that long he's probably some
businessman explorer checking out the
island that's what it's communicating to
me and the brief imagery we got of him
but for all I know it could be different
one thing that the game does is that as
it gets later into the game it deals a
lot more mystical supernatural elements
I don't know if the movies gonna do that
but I think it's smart to keep it much
more grounded in reality for especially
for its first trailer I'm excited for it
I I feel I have hope for it I'm not
gonna get my hopes too high from what I
said in my anticipation thought it seems
like it's aiming to deliver on most of
those things their heart seems like it's
in the right place and maybe the movie
will turn out great in the end anyway
what do you guys think of the Tomb
Raider trailer you guys excited for it I
am I hopes for this man I do you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification down and follow me at the
greg alba on instagram and twitter and
check out our patreon become a patreon
attack today